ten years ago California became the
first state to ban smoking in bars hi
I'm Nick Gillespie for recent TV there
was a time when Americans would have
been outraged at politicians for telling
bar owners that they couldn't allow
smoking in their own bars if somebody
told me luring your guests are not going
to be able to smoke in your restaurant
no matter what you think I would have
never believed that could possibly
happen in the first place
lorring de martini owns the van's
restaurant and bar in the Bay Area city
of Belmont when you talk about nanny
state that's what California is that
nanny state stuff might play in
California but a decade ago I figured
other places wouldn't put up with being
pushed around by politicians people are
killing themselves smoking these evil
cigarettes geez was I wrong
politicians just keep pushing today
thousands of cities of fans of some sort
some child welfare departments won't let
smokers a dodge just possessing
cigarettes is illegal at some parks in
Georgia
the city of Chicago want lead actors
smoke on stage which is why he wants
e-cigarettes and hit musicals like
Jersey Boys back in Belmont
councilmembers upped the ante with a new
law that bans smoking in all sorts of
new places that covers places where
people wait so wait for buses wait in
the ATM lie and wait to buy tickets
reason magazines Jacob solemn is the
author of for your own good a book about
the anti-smoking movement and then on
top of that it's within 20 feet of all
those locations at D martinis restaurant
customers often smoke outside near a
back entrance but the new law forbids
even that they can't come out here in
smoke they got to be 20 feet from the
nearest door or window and that lands
them well in the street at the van's you
have to stand on the street to have a
cigarette oh that's pretty crazy it
smokings been banned just about
everywhere comedian Denis Leary joked
about it years ago smoke in your
apartment under a blanket with all the
lights out is that the rule now huh I
bet some politicians are itching to ban
that too but they could never ban
smoking in private homes banning smoking
in a private home be very hard to do
because that's your property you can do
what you want inside don't be so sure
the most controversial part of belmonts
new law targets people who smoke in
their own homes you can smoke in a
single-family residence but you can't
smoke if you share a ceiling or a floor
with someone else so that means people
can't smoke in their own homes if they
happen to live in an apartment or
condominium last I checked I'm pretty
sure I live in America David Scott rents
an apartment in Belmont when I get home
every day from work I I like to sit down
and have a cigarette I mean what I do in
my house is my deal and not anybody
else's if Scott does this once the new
law takes effect in January and his
neighbor complains he might just get a
visit from a police officer the
cigarettes come out of the house with a
cigarette up off your hands enough
citations you can be evicted for smoking
inside your own apartment how about that
comedy becomes reality
me I'm coming out I'm gonna shoot right
here my bad yeah it was after a resident
at this retirement home complained about
smelling smoke from his neighbor's unit
that the Belmont City Council took up
the cause of in-home smoking one of the
council members in voted for the ban was
Dave worden we've heard from many many
people over the last year that have no
option their option is to move their
option is to die anti-smoking ads
suggest that smoke wafts through vents
and walls and hurts little kids it was
something then mayor coral and firebox
worried about I am thinking of the
children that is the most important
thing not necessarily if the restaurants
not necessarily of the condos but of the
children in this community children
children children look smoking is one of
the worst things you can do to your body
but how dangerous is secondhand smoke is
it's legal to have a gun in your
apartment but you can't shoot it through
them through the wall because you're
affecting somebody else if smoking is
like shooting a gun through the wall
then we should ban smoking in apartments
a 2006 Surgeon General report examined
people who live with smokers breathing
secondhand smoke in close quarters year
after year the report declared that
secondhand smoke increases a non-smokers
risk of lung cancer by about twenty to
thirty percent it's not a bullet through
the wall but it still sounds bad Council
has the right to enact ordinances for
the health safety and welfare of the
population of Belmont politicians in
Belmont and elsewhere used the report to
justify strict bans but what does a
twenty to thirty percent increase in
risk really mean you're talking about a
very small risk of lung cancer in
non-smokers to begin with less than one
percent lifetime risk and then you're
boosting it by maybe 20% maybe 30% it's
still below 1 percent lifetime risk and
this is for people who live with smokers
for decades in other words whether
you're a nonsmoker who never breeze a
whiff of secondhand smoke or you live
with a smoker for 20 years you still
have less than 1% chance of
lung cancer try to extrapolate from
those studies to say that if you happen
to sit next to a smoker in a bar or
restaurant but you happen to live in the
same apartment building with a smoker
and occasionally you can smell the smoke
that you have any kind of measurable
risk it's completely absurd but Belmonte
lawmakers didn't see it that way
shoot your gun just don't shoot it
through my apartment building I wanted
to ask Dave worden more about that but
neither he nor any of the others who
voted for the band wanted to be
interviewed think about people with lung
problems they have a right to they have
a right to health safety and welfare
what a politician's act like they're the
only reason we're not all wheezing from
secondhand smoke I actually like smoking
bans I just don't like it when the
government does the banning our guests
tell us overwhelmingly that a smoke-free
environment is very important to them
big hotel chains like Mary and Weston
have gone smoke-free because their
customers hate smoking apartment owners
and countless other businesses are eager
to cater to non-smokers and remember the
retirement home that was at the center
of the Belmont ban the smoking resident
was grandfathered in from an old policy
but the current policy is no smoking
the owner banned smoking too long ago
but that didn't stop politicians from
forcing the whole city to ban smoking if
somebody told me that they were going to
ban smoking inside private homes and you
know 2007 I would have said bollocks to
that nobody would actually let that pass
but people have the same attitude when
they started first started banning
smoking in bars you may like the nanny
state when it swashes something you hate
but sooner or later politicians will go
after something like well next it'll be
you won't be able to barbecue outside
your house of your Belmonte some places
have already banned outdoor grilling
trees and flowers can irritate people
with asthma and allergies how long till
some politician wants to ban your
begonias you see I just wish more people
with love freedom more than they hate
tobacco tobacco is a No
win situation for all of us and if we
can't stop ourselves the government
should help us stop and Belmonts not
alone recently other cities have passed
laws that target in-home smoking and
that is our responsibility to take care
of everybody this isn't the American Way
our founding fathers didn't expect that
we were incapable of running our own
country I mean that's We the People is
what we're trying to do and they're
saying no you're the people that we need
to take care of and I'm so they're going
I don't think I need you to take care of
me how far will the bans go
don't ask me ten years ago I had no idea
that the bureaucrats would be barging
through our front doors for reason TV
I'm Nick Gillespie